He was the king of Kung Fu,
the deadliest human fighting machine
that the world has ever seen.
Bringing a new level of
excitement of the silver screen.
He established himself as
the first oriental superstar
build as the fittest man
on the planet.
He has the world at his feet.
Then suddenly he was gone dead at the
age of 32 and the almost 50 years since
then,
his legend has propelled Bruce
Lee to mythical proportions.
In this week's biographics,
we go beyond the legends and
reveal the Real Bruce Lee.
The trials here,
the wells would knew as Bruce Lee was
born on November the 27th of 1940 and the
Jackson Street hospital in
San Francisco's China town.
His mother gracefully.
It was the company in
our husbands the Axle,
Hawaii Chong on a tour of the United
States with a Cantonese opera company of
Hong Kong.
Grace named the child
Jew Fang meaning return.
Again,
that's the doctor delivering him,
nicknamed him.
Bruce Lee's stayed in San Francisco for
five months before returning to Hong
Kong,
but the heat and the humidity of
Asia did not agree with baby Bruce.
He became a sickly child with his
mother constantly doting on him.
Grace has already lost a Charles and it
was determined that she would not lose a
seconds.
As he grew older there,
Bruce became stronger.
In fact,
he became so active that
his mother nicknamed him,
never sits still.
The only time he stopped running,
jumping,
or striking the air was when he was
curled up in the corner with a book in his
hands.
His long hours of reading into the nice
caused him to become near scientists and
at age six he required reading bosses.
Bruce grew up in a crowded bus
or flat along with his family.
There was that if his late brother so
that nearly 20 people were squashed into
the a chaotic household.
Still the leaves were among the wealthiest
families in Hong Kong along with his
opera income,
how he and received payments
from rental properties.
Bruce spent much of his time amusing
himself on the streets of Hong Kong.
He showed me listen to interest in school
and would often cut class to hang out
on the streets with local hoods.
By the time he was 10 he had developed
a pension for practical jokes.
These started out innocent enough,
but soon took on a more sinister touch
once he pushed his sister Phoebe into a
swimming pool and she retaliated by
holding his head under the water until he
promised to never do it again.
From that day on,
he promised,
dude,
never go in a swimming pool.
Yeah,
yeah.
Bruce is acts in Korea.
Began that just three months thanks to
his father's connections in the local
entertainment industry.
His first real acting role
occurred when he was six years old.
He plays a rebellious streak.
Kids in the movie,
beginning of a boy in that film,
he had the first of many onscreen fights.
He was building this and a string of
films that followed as Lee sue long or
Leila.
So Dragon.
Bruce loved the life of a young actor.
Often he would be picked up.
It's 2:00 AM leaping from his beds
and excitedly rushing out the door.
In his later films,
he played teenage rebels who invariably
ended up in a climactic fight scene.
From the very start,
he developed certain trademark mannerisms
which would later become famous.
The admonishing finger,
the thumb wiped across his nose,
the steady unflinching gaze.
By the time he was 18 Bruce
had appeared in 20 films,
the most famous of which was the orphan,
which was his own leading role.
At the age of 12 Bruce began
attending lasalle college.
A Catholic boy's school is teachers
that found him to be daisy,
stubborn and rebellious.
The Chinese students of Bruce and school
felt a strong rivalry with the British
students who attended King
George the fifth school,
which was up the hill.
Bruce became the leader of a gang that
hung out after school behind the playing
field of the rival school.
The boys would shout taunts
at the British students.
Often with the results that fee fist
fights would break out the rumbles.
They were often broken up by the police.
Phone calls and visits by the police
became a regular occurrence of Billy
household.
His father was furious at the way,
would cost that Bruce was taking and
imposed strict restrictions on him,
but he was not home enough for them
to have any real effects with fighting
becoming a major part of his life.
Bruce began thinking about
the subjects most of the time.
He later recalled that he always fought
with his gang behind him using chairs as
weapons,
but what was happening,
he wonders if he got caught on his
own without his gang to back him up.
Could he protect himself?
He decided not to take any chances and
it became convinced this in order to
survive,
he needed to be trained in the
most effective of the martial arts.
Kung Fu,
Bruce's father had taught
him some Tai Chi moves,
but the slow flowing movements where
there's this'll health and a street fight
at the age of 13 he began
learning wing Chung.
I'm the trainer William Young.
Bruce threw himself into his lessons,
practicing constantly and
making rapid progress.
Young was so impressed with his young
students that he introduced him to his
Mazda or revered older man named Yip man.
The master decided to take on
Bruce as a personal students.
At first,
Bruce was only interested in
learning how to street fight,
but as the lessons continued,
Yup.
A man introduced him to the finer
points of the OSC meditation,
breathing and balance
while training under Yep.
Bruce learns not only to
master the physical techniques,
but also to quell the interference
of emotions such as fear and anger.
Despite his developing
skills as a martial artist,
Bruce was still a troublemaker at school.
At Age 15 he was expelled from the South
College ending up at in Francis Xavier
College on the other side of town,
one of his teachers there,
brother Edward's encouraged to Bruce two
releases energies by entering the 1958
boxing championships held between his
new school and King George the fifth
school.
Bruce likes the idea and trained
vigorously for the upcoming challenge.
When the competition finally took place,
Bruce breezed his way through
the preliminary rounds,
knocking out three opponents
in the first rounds.
In the final,
he faced Gary alums who had held
the title for the last three years.
Bruce was able to use the blocking
moves he had learned from when Chung to
negate the power of his opponents.
Then in the third round,
he landed a devastating blow
which put alums on the canvas.
Bruce had won the title despite having
the prestige of being inner city boxing
champ.
Bruce continued to get in trouble
with his teachers and then the police.
Finally,
his mother suggested that he returns
to the country of his birth to claim
citizenship before he turned 18 at
which time it would be too late.
His father agreed knowing that Bruce is
future depended on him getting away from
his peers.
On April 15th,
1959 Bruce gathered up his meager
belongings and set off for his three week
journey across the Pacific.
Before he left,
his mother slept $100 into his pockets
and his father gave him a further $15 he
was booked onto the ship
as a third class passenger,
but spends most of his time in first
costs by giving dance lessons to other
passengers.
On May the 17th he fulfilled his mother's
prophecy when she names him returning
to the place of his birth.
San Francisco.
Bruce stayed with a friend of his father
making a meager income by giving dance
lessons.
During his first few
months in San Francisco,
he met several local karate students
who encouraged him to teach Kung Fu,
but Bruce,
he was not yet ready to make that leap.
A few months after arriving,
he moved into the boarding house,
really a chow,
a family,
friends,
and deep began to work as
a waiter in a restaurant.
He also enrolled in Edison technical
high school when Seattle Hells and Asian
Culture Day,
teachers at the school asked to breeze
to give a kung food demonstration in the
audience.
That day was James de Mille format,
US army heavyweight boxing
champion scanning the audience,
Bruce Notice to mill and
invited him up to spar with him.
Do we all thought he could easily take
out the slide Chinaman but were surprised
to discover that he was unable to lay
a finger on Bruce who was able to block
and it's counter with deadly efficiency.
After the demonstration,
demille asked Bruce to
teach him some moves.
Before long,
Bruce had a devoted core
of serious students.
Bruce applied himself to his
education for the first time,
earning his diploma from Edison tack
with high enough grades to be admitted to
the University of Washington in Seattle.
While in college,
he kept up with his Kung Fu training,
but he would not let his teaching
come before his own learning.
He would train it for up
to 40 hours each week,
developing new techniques and borrowing
from all forms in order to create the
most functional fighting style.
And in October of 1963 22 year old
Bruce quit his job at Ruby Charles
restaurants and opened
his own training academy,
the Jun Fan Gung Fu institutes.
He lives at the back in
a small window to swim.
It was around this time the Bruce awesome
as a fellow students at Washington by
the name of Linda Emery.
They began dating though Lindsay hit
the budding romance from her parents,
the institutes,
it did well.
And by 1964 Bruce was ready to open
up a larger equipment in Oakland,
California.
He closed the door of the first academy
and men told his assistant tacky camera
to reopen the school in Chinatown as a
private club for his regular students.
Before opening the Oakland's Queen,
Bruce attended the international karate
tournament in Long Beach where he had
been invited to give a demonstration here.
He wowed the crowd with
his soon to be famous,
one inch punch.
It was here,
the Bruce also first Matt
Filipino martial artists,
Dan Inosanto,
who would become his number one students.
Bruce gave further demonstrations is soon
had a thriving business in Oakland's.
His was to build up a nest egg and then
bring Linda from Seattle where they
would marry,
but those plans were swept aside.
When Lindsay Roots of Bruce
saying that she was pregnant,
Bruce,
he was delighted.
Despite the protestations
of Linda's family,
they were married in a small ceremony.
On August the 17th 1964 Bruce and his
new bride moved in with James Lee and his
family.
James was a traditionally trained
Kung Fu man who was looking for a more
practically efficient style.
He works with Bruce to build
up his Oakland's cal loon.
They offered their skills to anyone who
was seriously interested in learning how
to fight.
In early 1965 they traditional
Chinese Kung Fu instructor named Wong.
Jack man earns the CPAP with teaching
Chinese secret fighting arts to
Westerners.
He was enraged and it's largely
to build his own reputation.
He challenged Bruce to a fight with a
wage at the loser would have to close his
school when long turned up for the fight.
He half expected Bruce to back down,
but Bruce was hindsons ready
for action as surprised.
Wong tried to throw in
some last minute rules,
no ige apps,
no growing kicks,
et Cetera,
that Bruce rejected them saying,
I'm not standing for any of that.
You've made the challenge.
It's all out.
It's no holds barred.
The match was sloppy.
After a few week punches longterm to run,
Bruce ran after him and punched
him in the back of their heads,
but he couldn't land a finishing punch.
One finally gave up and does entourage.
Dragged him off without a word Bruce was
not happy with is showing the fight had
been too messy and she had become winded.
It spurs him on to begin an intense
regimen of physical training,
which he would keep up for the rest of us
life.
February
the first 1965 Linda gave birth to a son,
Brandon.
Three days later,
Bruce was given his first
Hollywood screen test,
has stylist to the stars.
Jay Sebring had been in attendance at
the Long Beach Karate tournaments where
Bruce had demonstrated his one inch punch
and it mentions and producers who were
costing roles in a new Charlie Chan movie.
He didn't get that role,
but he was offered another role as Keto,
the sidekick to the Green Hornet
and it projected TV series.
The series premiers on September the
ninth 1966 introducing American audiences
to come through for the first time.
Young viewers were amazed
at what they saw and Cato,
the sidekick soon became
the real star of the show.
Bruce began making personal
appearances all over the country.
Unfortunately,
the Green Hornet wasn't such a hit
with adult audiences who saw it as too
unrealistic and too much
of a copycat of Batman.
After 26 weekly episodes,
it was canceled.
Despite its popularity as Keto
Nunu roles popped up for briefs.
He did manage to make a little cash
with guest appearances on long street
blondie,
and here comes the bride's once again,
the he turned his energies
to teaching Kung Fu,
although he never intended it.
His techniques seem developed
into a new fighting school.
He called it [inaudible] Condo,
the way of the intercepting
fist in February of 1967
and Bruce opened his third
Kuhn and is Chinatown just a
few blocks from dodger stadium.
At the suggestion of the Green
Hornets assistant producer,
he raised his fees from $22 per
month to as much as $50 per hour.
Eventually,
his rates went up to $250 per
hour with director Roman Polanski,
even flying him out to Switzerland for
private celebrity students included Steve
McQueen,
Lee Corbin and Kareem Abdul Jabbar.
He also trained established martial
art masters including Chuck Norris,
Joe Louis,
and Mike Stone.
Between them,
those three had won every major karate
championship in the United States.
On April the 19th 1969 Lindsey
gave birth to a daughter Shannon.
A few weeks later.
Bruce suffered a severe back injury
while lifting a 125 pound barbell.
The doctor had told him
to forget to Kung Fu,
you wouldn't have a kick
again for three months.
He lay flat on his back and
fell into a deep depression.
After six months,
he finally began training again working
through his pain in a short amount of
time.
He was back to his own self.
It was at the same time the Bruce
was working with screenwriters,
sterling silver fans and actor Lee Marvin
or what was to be his breakout film,
the silent flute.
The film never got to the shooting stage,
but cellophane did get Bruce
a cameo on the TV series.
Long Street.
Shortly after shooting
the Long Street episode,
Bruce flew to Hong Kong to arrange for
his now widowed mother to come and live
in the United States.
When he stepped off the plane,
he was shocked at the reaction.
The Green Horn is had been playing in
movie theaters and did it made Bruce the
Chinese hero.
He was bombarded by reporters and spent
the next two weeks doing the rounds of
the local TV talk shows.
Bruisers fame did not escape the attention
of the key players in the Hong Kong
film industry.
The shore brothers,
they produced two thirds of the
Chinese films in the wells vans walls,
a film production assembly line with
actors and crew being grossly underpaid.
They offered Bruce a seven year contracts
for just $2,000 per film and tighten
them down.
Then Bruce was approached by Raymond
Chow with Golden Harvest Studios who
offered $15,000 for two movies.
Bruce,
while he signed on the
dotted line and the rest,
as they say,
is history.
Bruce,
his first major role as an
adult was in the big boss.
The film was shot in Bangkok
in the middle of a heat wave.
We've no air conditioning,
polluted water and no fresh food.
It was hardly the star's life
that Bruce had dreamed of,
but it was all worth it because
he was finally on his way.
The big boss Premiers in October of 1971
Bruce and Linda sat in the audience in
nervous anticipation.
The movie ended to complete silence.
Then utter chaos broke out.
The ecstatic crowd practically mobbed as
you tried to leave the fares out within
three weeks,
the film took in more than
$3 million in Hong Kong.
Smashing all records.
Bruce's second film for Golden Harvest,
fists of fury was even more popular.
Smashing the record.
Saps by the big boss on the streets,
sold out tickets went for $50 a pop.
Bruce,
it become a superstar almost overnight.
Suddenly he was unable to walk down
the street without drawing a crowd,
but it's adding to the United States.
Bruce was excited about a new TV
series that was in production,
tentatively called for warrior.
It was the story of a Chinese Shaolin
monk who gets transplanted in the American
West.
Bruce desperately wanted the pot,
yet he was shocked and disappointed to
learn that he was considered to Chinese
for the role.
You remember him.
He was supposed to play
the role of a Chinese man.
The Bob was actually given to an
American accent named David Cara.
Diane Ans retitled Kung Fu briefs dealt
with this rejection by throwing himself
into his next project.
A film.
He rose by himself,
called the way of the Dragon.
He decided to do this
completely by himself.
He would produce direct cost,
choreograph scout locations
and star in the movie.
He even played percussion
for the movie soundtrack.
The movie was shot only $130,000
budget on location in Rome.
In the climactic scene,
Bruce recreated a one-on-one
gladiatorial contest with Chuck Norris.
Way Of the dragon was a smash hit.
It's taken in five point $5 million
in Hong Kong alone in the wake of its
release.
Bruce had planned to take some time off
to recover from his grueling schedule.
In October of 1972 he
has the basketball star,
Kareem Abdul Jabbar was in Hong Kong.
He quickly arranged some action
sequences with a seven foot,
two inch form of students that
could be used in this next project,
game of death,
having shots,
20 minutes of footage
of the game of death.
Bruce finally got the call from Hollywood
that he had been waiting for for so
long.
Warner brothers now saw Bruce
as a bankable commodity.
They wanted him to start in a US s
martial arts film as we're willing to give
them complete control
over the fight scenes.
The entire feature was
called enter the Dragon.
The filming of enter the Dragon placed
enormous demands on Bruce's physical
energy.
You couldn't sleep at night.
He lost weight and to skin pales
and he started to look ill.
We're filming wraps up Bruce Sands and
a tiny dubbing room on May the 10th 1973
looping dialogue in order
to achieve complete silence.
The air conditioning was shutoff.
Bruce went to the bathroom to
wash his face and collapsed.
He was seized with a fit of
vomiting and struggled to breathe.
Rush to the hospital.
He was diagnosed with cerebral edema
and then released around noon on January
the 20th 1973 Bruce Santini as Hong
Kong study hunched over his books and
papers.
Around 2:00 PM Raymond Chow arrived.
You've discussed script ideas for
game of death staying for two hours.
In the early evening.
Bruce drove over to the apartment of
Betty Ting Pei and actress who had wanted
to play a lead role in the film.
Around seven 30 Bruce complained of a
headache and asked Betty if he could lay
on her bed.
The parotid glands image Raymond Chow,
which a restaurant for dinner.
When Betsy went into rouse Bruce,
she was unable to wake him.
She called Chow,
who rushed over unable to wake Bruce.
They called for a doctor,
the martial arts superstar.
He was rushed to hospital,
but nothing could be done.
Bruce Lee with stat on the
cusp of worldwide domination,
the world's fittest man was gone,
but the legends of Bruce Lee,
while that was just beginning,
so I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive
over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.